here are the latest calls between former
President Obama and president Trump
hello hey Barack you on this wiretapping
thing but you know I didn't do that I
know but we still have to investigate it
otherwise it'll look like I'm just
mentally unstable and the crazy thing
you said in order to not look creepy
yes exactly two crazies multiplied
together
cancel each other out and make me that
crazy man
that's great x great equals that crazy
hello Iraq I just learned that March is
Women's History Month that's right it's
a great way to shine some light on
women's achievements well if you ask me
women are only good for one thing
creating their own destinies without
men's interference oh that's like
Michelle's in the room what do you think
my decision not to get a dog I think
it's a mistake you can benefit from
having someone in your life who loves
you unconditionally and expects nothing
in return
that's what chard spices for panting
wait till you see the video it took a
bit with a cookie others hello what do
you want
we gotta write a movie or something what
the hell are you talking about first you
can't make it sing stab accusing you of
tapping my phone
we're like rivals no we're not I'm an
ex-president and you're an insane person
I got another title for a book you could
run what is it little Donny goes to jail
[Applause]
you
you